Joe we're here at London Film comic-con
you have been one busy guy today they
were all wanted to get your autograph
and to chat to you what we want to ask
you right now there is last time we
spoke you hadn't seen the red wedding
episode what did you make of it
- Starro oh my god I mean I was just
saying how it's it's just so remarkable
that even having been well aware of what
was coming you know I had read the
script I knew exactly what was happening
it was still just really really shocking
I mean I've even you know I'd even heard
a lot about it as well that you know the
episode because I hadn't watched it when
everyone else had seen it and yeah it
was just it but I think again it's what
the show does really well it says it's
not afraid it doesn't flinch from those
kind of things and and I think it was I
mean it's supposed to be brutal and
that's exactly what it was it was really
hard watching you know really good
friends of yours getting dispatched in a
really horrible horrible way you know
Oona and Richard and Michelle you know I
know them know them all pretty well and
it's not a nice thing to see your
friends getting murdered now fortunately
Gendry was far away from that although
having his own little trouble as well
obviously I would not see the way he
rode that boat at the end of the series
up I think it bodes well for him
oh my money wouldn't be on him making it
to the other side of that sea oh no a
ski what advice would you give you if
you could give him some advice for next
season so we learn how to swim mate
first of all it's pretty important life
skill mate you know you've been stuck in
that armoury for so long if you're going
to take care of the real needs in like
you know swimming one of them may be
thrown about - yeah yeah maybe that's I
mean I'm sure we'll have plenty of time
to practice now by the time he gets to
the side we'll be like Steve Redgrave we
took less time also about what an
awesome King Andrew it made yeah
and if you could have anyone as your
queen of Westeros who would it be and
why
oh good question because I think every
the great thing about all the characters
in Game of Thrones is that they've got
they've all got sort of positives and
negative like hardly anyone's flawless
are they because even you know Daenerys
is you know very strong and a and a
powerful woman who end up with a
conscience who would make a great Queen
but she has that sort of she has that
petulant side as well it's just good
which is a bit
to handle tsunami am I think Kendra
might just buy the time if he ever
became king you might just want any easy
life I don't know who he's gonna get it
with in Westeros I mean Arya she'll be a
handful I mean they don't get me started
on Suzy I mean I would never happen
anyway um so yeah I just have no I have
no idea
oh sure would be nuts
uh-huh you're as bit feisty as well
isn't it star is pretty feisty see we're
just knock it which is ticking off the
list he's pitting he's a picky guy
Gendry um definitely I don't think you
should hang out with Walder Frey's lot
either yeah the one decent fright for a
girl is she's got it you know um I mean
who does that actually let you know
Margaery Tyrell like what are you
kidding me no she's she's weird
I don't know about your new character
stay celibate you know just rule on your
own mate you mentioned sense either
you know Kendra is always saying to I
you know you should have had a different
hit list it should have been there's a
Geoffrey and so on if you could have
Aya's hit list now who would be on it
who was it that killed Yaron was that
armory Lodge someone like that that's
right I think he'd get I mean I think I
think you know Genji's life has been
such a puncher all the life that we've
seen anyway it's been punctuated by him
so just about starting to trust people
I'm starting to feel like he has a real
connection with someone for the first
time then they get kind of wrenched away
from him so Yaron was that first man who
I think he Kenji started to feel like
joining the Brotherhood would be a
really good idea and that he might
belong there and Brotherhood you know
that again G that word is alien I think
also kendrys got a he's got a slightly
wiser head on his shoulders just in the
sense that you know arya still got that
fire that than that even that youthful
naivety and she just wants she just is
impulsive those decisions that she makes
on who to who to kill so I think I don't
know I think he would as he said to her
you know you could have killed could
have picked Joffrey could have picked
Tywin Lannister and I think as a as a as
a duo take those throughout
there was nearly one now is anyone left
in the show that you haven't worked with
yet you'd love to work with you could
write your own script who do you want to
work with honey there's so many people
there are so many people that's it's
almost it's a joke I mean you know
Peters been here today
and and I I just I'm such a big fan of
his you know his work in the show that
today just just a yes stand on the other
side of the camera from and what you
know watching it up-close live would be
brilliant God every everyone oh god I
like to help with some of my mates
unsetting like Gwendoline Christie be
good to work with kit and Alfie diana
rigg be brilliant to work with I've
already worked with Natalie Dormer
no offense storm over done and yeah just
I mean just everyone I'm such it it you
know the kids as well I think Isaac is
great and and and you know and a little
little art and and I think it's it's
just it's just so it's so incredible the
way the show's been cast there's so many
great accident I think we should all
have a big the last episode should be a
big party everyone is in an episode
together getting drunk I love it let's
do it and finally what are you looking
forward to for season four um I don't
know B just didn't see what happens with
Gendry really like a sassy didn't look
great at the end of season three so this
means you can see a first of all if you
if you can if you can you can navigate
his way somewhere safe and also I think
yeah because in terms of everyone else's
storylines it's kind of its kind of
pointless Pecola now you know I haven't
read you know book wise it's gone ahead
of where I've read now so I genuinely
don't know what to expect and so it'll
just be will just be I like to see
howhow Maisie gets on with the Hound
but but yeah from a personal point of
view it just be good to see if you can
make it to dry land
what Gendry does next because you know
we haven't seen him on his own
really before and and it would be really
really intriguing to see what see if you
can I don't know for once in his life
fashion a positive opportunity Joe it's
been living speaking to you again thanks
so much for your time I really
appreciate you thanks having me again
looks to speak to
you